so the first antidepressants were made
from of all things rocket fuel
left over after World War two which is
fitting seeing as today one in five
soldiers develop depression or
post-traumatic stress disorder or both
but is not just soldiers that are at
high risk for these diseases it's
firefighters yard doctors cancer
patients aid workers refugees anyone
exposed to trauma or major life stress
and yet despite how commonplace these
disorders are our current treatments if
they work at all only suppress symptoms
in 1798 when Edward Jenner discovered
the first vaccine it happened to be for
smallpox
he didn't just discover a prophylactic
for a disease but a whole new way of
thinking that medicine could prevent
disease however for over 200 years this
prevention was not believed to extend to
psychiatric diseases until 2014 when my
colleague and I accidentally discovered
the first drugs that might prevent
depression and PTSD we discovered the
drugs in mice and we're currently
studying whether they work in humans and
these preventive psychopharmaceuticals
are not antidepressants they're a whole
new class of drug and they work by
increasing stress resilience so let's
call them resilience enhancers so think
back to a stressful time that you've
since recovered from maybe a breakup or
an exam you missed a flight stress
resilience is the active biological
process that allows us to bounce back
after stress similar to if you have a
cold in your immune system fights it off
and insufficient resilience in the face
of a significant enough stressor can
result in a psychiatric disorder such as
depression in fact most cases of major
depressive disorder are initially
triggered by stress and from what we've
seen so far in mice resilience enhancers
can protect against purely biological
stressors like stress hormones and
social and psychological stressors
like bullying and isolation so here is
an example where we gave mice three
weeks of high levels of stress hormones
so in other words a biological stressor
without a psychological component and
this causes depressive behavior and if
we give three weeks of antidepressant
treatment beforehand it has no
beneficial effects but a single dose of
a resilience enhancer given a week
before completely prevents the
depressive behavior even after three
weeks of stress this is the first time a
drug has ever been shown to prevent the
negative effects of stress depression
and PTSD are chronic often lifelong
clinical diseases they also increase the
risk of substance abuse homelessness
heart disease Alzheimer's suicide the
global cost of depression alone is over
three trillion dollars per year but now
imagine a scenario where we know someone
is predictively at high risk for
exposure to extreme stress say a Red
Cross volunteer going into an earthquake
zone in addition to the typhoid vaccine
we could give her a pill or an injection
of a resilience enhancer before she
leaves so when she is held at gunpoint
by looters or worse she would at least
be protected against developing
depression or PTSD after the fact it
won't prevent her from experiencing the
stress but it will allow her to recover
from it and that's what's revolutionary
here by increasing resiliency we can
dramatically reduce her susceptibility
to depression and PTSD possibly saving
her from losing her job her home her
family or even her life after Jenner
discovered the smallpox vaccine a lot of
other vaccines rapidly followed it was
over a hundred and fifty years before
tuberculosis vaccine was widely
available why in part because society
believed that tuberculosis made people
more sensitive and creative and
empathetic and that it was caused by
Constitution and not biology
and similar things are still said today
about depression and just as generous
discovery opened the door for all of the
vaccines that followed after the drugs
we've discovered open the possibility of
a whole new field preventive
psychopharmacology but whether that's 15
years away or 150 years away depends not
just on the science but on what we as a
society choose to do with it thank you
[Applause]